did you see the Kanye you a't got the
answer sway so Kanye goes on sway sway's
universe is like the number one hip-hop
show at the time maybe still is he was
trying to do a deal with Mark Parker
from Nike before Adidas was Nike yeah
Nike said no and Kanye was trying to get
some kind of deal to happen to get his
shoe ideas up and so he comes on the
show and he's like I'm going to put Mark
Parker on blast and he starts going
after Mark Parker and what he's
frustrated is like he's not he's not
getting the respect that he feels that
he deserves to get somebody to invest in
his daa company and then he he goes on
this crazy rank he says I'm standing up
and I'm telling you I am Warhol I am the
number one most impactful artists of Our
Generation I am Shakespeare in the flesh
Walt Disney Nike Google now who's going
to be the Michi family and stand up and
let me create more when people hear him
they think he's crazy right it's like
what the heck is he even saying during
the Renaissance Italy was the center and
Florence was the center of Italy for
that's where the statue David was is
Michelangelo all that was all happened
in Florence and the wealthy family that
was sponsoring all of these artists were
the medes so Michelangelo got funded by
the medes so all the artists went to the
medes influence to get sponsorship
because that's how you made money like a
big family sponsors you and then you
make the statue of David right so if you
go around Florence it's all it's all the
medich family interesting so he's saying
who's going to be the medich family and
stand up and let me create more he's
calling out Nike Google all these
companies like sponsor me to help me
create more or do you want to
marginalize me till I'm out of my Mo
meaning like he's he was at the Pinnacle
of like his rap career he's at's he's
white hot and he's trying to make
clothing and like he only has so much
focus and he's losing relevancy when
he's not rapping he's just making
clothing people don't know him as much
he's not going to be in a white hot
moment anymore then sway comes on and
says uh what does sway say he says why
don't you
you bet on yourself why don't you take a
few steps back and then that's when
Kanye flips out and he's like you ain't
got the answer sway you ain't got the
like yelling them you ain't got the
answer sway I've been doing this more
than you maybe I have seen sway says
doing what you ain't got the answers and
so it's like telling Kanye to take a few
steps back is not what he wanted to hear
y right and so's like no no no no no I'm
just trying to understand like I I put
out a clothing line myself and I haven't
risked Millions but it's a few hundred
thousand and Kanye then says but it
ain't Ralph level talking about Ralph
Lauren right it ain't Ralph level what's
the name of your clothing brand nobody
knows people just raged on Kanye after
like he's he's so um like he's yelling
at him it's not and it's true like how
he reacted I'm not a fan of I think I
did see this but but but like it's the
thinking behind it yeah that is for me
inspirational same right it's like
here's this guy who went from being you
know a producer to a rapper to winning
all these award now thinking this is at
the beginning of his fashion career
thinking that he could build a fashion
Empire he wasn't a billionaire yet right
he's on his way up he's trying to make
his first deal he didn't sign Adidas yet
he didn't do the Yeezys he hasn't done
that thing but he's trying to make it
happen and he's trying to go through
Nike the belief that he is the greatest
artist of the generation and the belief
that he deserves to work with the
biggest companies in the world that they
should be betting on him saying that I
am Michelangelo the Michi family you
should bet on me when he hasn't done it
yet right it's like it's aspirational
yeah and then when when sway kind of
Compares himself to Kanye say well I put
my own CL clothing line
out the fact that like the disgust in
just the levels of thinking again I
don't think he handled it well is being
very disrespectful but it was it I don't
know that he was intentionally being
disrespectful just how he is yeah but
the but I I respect the the disrespect
like how are you think you're
your clothing line that failed that you
spent $100,000 on is not even close to
thinking what I'm thinking about like
how are you even not understanding this
giant chasm of a gap that we're talking
about here right and then it ain't Ralph
level right it's not Ralph Lauren nobody
knows any of your clothing brand not not
to insult the guy but to say like I'm
trying to be Ralph Lauren I'm trying to
make a giant
impact uh and so I just find like he was
at the beginning he doesn't he he's
nobody knows him as a fashion guy and he
thinks that he's Ralph Lauren has the
capabilities to be it and then the fact
that he went off and built a billion
dollar Empire in
shoes I just find it impressive I do too
I don't like how he came across and did
it but the thinking behind it I'm
jealous of yeah so I watched that clip
um I was just on a trip to Arizona and I
was bunking with room a friend of mine
Mark uh and so every morning I just to
just to tease him like I put that on
every day because like are you thinking
in your business like Ralph level are
you Warhol in what you do are you the
greatest of all time at the thing that
you do right and like none of us are
thinking that I don't think that enough
I want that aspirational level um so
it's funny to watch him flip out but
most people aren't seeing at least that
angle that's the angle I see out of it
and uh anyway welcome to the podcast
what are we talking about here Jamie
this your show it's your show we're
going to combine show three tidbits I
think three multiple tidbits one is did
you ever see the Chappelle bit or
Chappelle discussion on I think it was
Jimmy Fallon about Kanye coming into
onto the Chappelle Show when he was like
unknown no oh you it's hilarious he he
says something in the same vein like he
he believed in his greatness before
anyone knew who he was and I remember
Kanye was one of the first musical guest
might have been the first musical guest
on Chappelle Show back in like 0203
whatever it was so Chappelle tells the
story that this guy Kanye that nobody
knows comes in with comment and love and
these other well-known artists at the
time and they're playing the new Jay-Z
record and on the Jay-Z record he says
something about Kanye in a in a
complimentary way Jay-Z does and so
Kanye just all of a sudden goes stop the
record and Rewind that and and Dave
Chappelle's he like everyone like who is
this guy what is he talking about he
made him say something else and then
after that he goes he takes his phone
call and um he said at the time we were
watching like the Rick James skip before
it was released and Kane goes to whoever
he's talking to no I I can't I'm at the
Chappelle show uh watching stuff that
hasn't been released yet and then he
pauses and he goes because my life is
dope and I do dope and hangs up the
phone everybody's like but they like
Kanye was born right like that was the
beginning but that's he always thought
big about himself that was one little
tidbit the second thing is on the on the
sponsorship thing like that whole idea
of I'm going to pay an artist to create
I didn't know that existed until so a
business partner of mine is a writer for
Family Guy been a writer for Family Guy
for 20 23 years original writer right
it's been there forever ran the show for
a while he's in real estate as well and
that's where we partnered up but I went
to Seth McFarland's birthday party in
well last year whenever the heck it was
and he's explaining like McFarland's
world like so fox or somebody paid him
like call it a half a billion $250
million simply for like three years
anything you think of you just it comes
through US kind of thing that's it if
you think of nothing okay we spent $250
million on you if you think of some
stuff that's great then then we'll take
it so the Orville came out of that and
some other projects but that idea that
your Artistry can be so incredible like
David with the what was the family medii
yeah yeah medich medich yeah Co Cosmo
deichi deichi is the the the name yeah
to think of like sponsorship for your
art for whatever you haven't created
like just create something I'm willing
to spend blows my mind so that's
interesting with Kanye I think those are
the only two bits I said three but I
don't remember the third one do you have
the answers
uh hopefully I don't know we'll see what
kind of questions you have we got we got
to come up with a a nickname for you
like not sway but something that fits
you better I don't know so people give
sway a lot of credit for how he handled
it because he didn't flip out on the way
back right and and it's true like he did
a good job but he also wasn't listening
because he asked Kanye earlier in the
interview like why do you need them why
do you need the Nike because he was
going on about Nike why do you need Nike
he's like I don't have the distribution
Kanye said I don't have the distribution
like I can't reach the people I might be
their I might be the biggest voice
because of what I can do in in music but
I don't have the factories I don't have
the distribution I can't get this thing
out and I can't just build it myself so
he told him that but he wasn't listening
so then he asked the same question
basically again later on and then Kanye
flips out is like you don't you don't
have the answers yeah you want to dive
into some brand stuff yeah yeah how can
I help let's go it's a good segue so
what what are you going to be Kanye at
I'm trying to figure that out podcasting
would be my easy answer if I were to
just give you a very quick answer like
this this is podcasting this is
podcasting enjoy this I love this medium
I love doing my podcast soon second
podcast is going to be releasing which
is everything I want to do so if you
were to ask me quick story I think you
know this but for the audience you know
had a big job in the states big
insurance company few hundred grand a
year Equity the whole nine set it down a
couple of years ago wife and kids at
home no second income um and went out to
be a brand have a few different
businesses associated with being a brand
and then we moved to the Dominican
Republic which is where we live today in
In pakana Living a really cool life down
there so really neat story right great
headlines living a cool life doing cool
things yeah exactly yeah my life is dope
because I do dope exactly but I don't
know how to go from A to B and so what
I've worked on recently is with bo uh
one of the guys that you work with is
building my Instagram so I've been
really heavily focused on Instagram and
the idea was you know that story is the
value proposition to others how do you
do that I'm miserable in a Cuban Ohio I
want to move to the Caribbean I want to
quit this job and I make 200 Grand 300
Grand 100 grand 50 Grand whatever it is
so my brand has been built around that
and it's getting even more traction with
specifically Dominican Americans who
want to make that move down to the to to
to Dr and it's blown up I went from
8,000 followers to 50,000 followers in
about two months and very highly engaged
thousands of shares per post all of that
stuff it's not just not just views lots
of DMs I have 50 right now that came in
in the last hour it's amazing and I
enjoy that I enjoy the community aspect
so the next step is monetization and
what I I already have the community you
you've attended an event of ours with
with cundy merge so I have the community
that's an easy monetization play that's
a different Community though it's a
different Community there's there's
relative there's a relative content
structure there in that we do talk about
and help people grow from wherever they
are or wherever they want to go right
whether that's entrepreneurship or
better health or whatever it might be
but I like the idea of the attention
converting to income by in in the form
of sponsorships ads that sort of thing
on a podcast so I I want to figure out
how to take this attention and monetize
it without having to sell somebody
something necessarily sure okay does
that make sense why podcast as an
execution I'll do a long short answer 16
years old I wanted to be an NFL
broadcaster that was my objective I was
all about it didn't want to go through
the motions of it I learned as I went
into college though I didn't want to go
work in Iowa on the classical radio
station to build my way up but the thing
I loved about uh the thing I wanted to
do the reason I wanted to be an NFL
broadcaster I learned in my 30s and 40s
as I unpacked my life was I love story
Stelling I love the ability to use
communication that's all I got I'm short
I'm bald I have no pigment but I can
communicate really really well I was
gifted with it so I want to be able to
use that Medium which is why NFL
broadcast like let me tell you the story
I'm seeing on the field was so appealing
so as I got into my job and I'm 17 18
years into this career and I'm miserable
and trying to find a way out I found
podcasting and it was the same idea like
wow I get to tell somebody's story
through me explore my curiosity so why
is it just it's the medium right now
there may be others that come out in the
future who knows that allows me to best
Express what I believe is my gift and my
purpose that too deep an answer no no no
no no I love I love I'm I'm sure you can
go even deeper here so here's what's
going through my mind you've blown up on
Instagram I have the content itself is
not
podcasting deep
knowledge it's it's a lot of fun it's a
lot of there's there's some education
there's commentary on news and there's
just some funny
a lot of funny skits of like what's it
like an insert whatever in in Dominican
Republic so you have a different
audience like you have people who are
there for a laugh and you have people
who are saying that's so true haa like
that's what I see all the time too and
then you have people who are who want to
move to Dominican they learn like hey
here's how you ship a car here's how
taxes work more tactical stuff correct Y
A lot of people who come from like a a
skit or fun background struggle moving
into
podcasting it's a different a audience
it's more serious and you can still have
fun in the podcast but it's not the
skits it's not as it's not as fun it's
harder to be able to especially if
you're telling somebody else's story
like you could do a podcast sitting down
and doing people who are from the Dr I
get it though it's a it's a
reach it's F and it's F it's like almost
a separate business model I'm thinking
now you have this traction already built
in with the Instagram account and
talking about Dr stories how do we turn
that into something and maybe that's not
the priority maybe that's not what you
want to do no no no that is it so yeah
my my my content is a balance of here's
a Bo taught me this like talk about how
I not how here's what you should do but
this is what I did right so how did we
how did we rent our house out in the US
so that we can move abroad like what
service did we use okay what what do you
say is a percentage of content between
like howto educational versus skits fun
7030 educational the skits are like a
throw and I do them every so often but
they get the most reach well that's the
thing right so like what's actually
generating the views for your CH for
your cuz that's all I see like I follow
you yep and those pop up I don't care
about the Dr apart from you yeah uh
shout out to all the Dr people watching
you know on your
channel no I get it though I thought you
were just doing skits I'm not consuming
your stuff but I I knew the news one you
did the green screen one popped y a few
of those but the only ones that I see
are the are the funny ones and so if
you're building an audience like if
those are the ones that are popping even
though it's
7030 by volume if the 30 ones are the
ones popping your audience is coming in
they're popping more so to give you an
idea on numbers right so if I a regular
educational one I probably get 50 to
880,000 views and a thousand shares
let's say with hundreds of comments or
maybe even thousands of comments and
interactions on those some of the funny
ones to your point they'll get like one
of them got like 700,000 views with
thousands of shares and so on and so
forth but the take out the two take out
that outlier the rest are probably 20%
more they probably get about 20%
the outliers are the ones that really
grow the channel yeah it's same for
YouTube same for it's like the one that
hit you know 700,000 that's reaching new
people yeah even if the other ones are
only doing 20 30% more that's still 20
30% more yeah but that's only on how
like 20,000 views how much are happening
on those ones on the education ones yeah
30 to 60 30 to 60 versus so it's like
the challenge is the 30 to 60 you're
going to get a lot of repeat people
coming back so it's not 30 new yeah true
the 700 was a lot of new the other one
that got a big reach was the news
newsworthy one that got like 1.2 or 1.3
million views you're getting a lot of
new that was right that was about a
train that's coming in and you know kind
the status of that but yeah and I think
I saw that one so all of the the ones
that are the major outliers you you
those are the ones gener like go and
look at your account and see how many
new followers you got because of that a
lot dis way disproportionate so you
can't Factor those out right um cuz the
other one ones are hitting your core
audience which is great we want that the
question then becomes how do you best
monetize that in a way that's fun for
you and also generates you know good
income the easiest thing that comes to
mind is not teaching people how to live
like a laptop lifestyle or initially
when we talked on your last show was
like how do I get out of teaching people
how to get out of their job into their
own business y right and that's that is
a passion thing for you I know I've seen
you help people I know it's like a huge
soft spot in your heart for helping
people quit their crappy jobs and get
into something good yeah you did that
with your business you haven't done that
with this account true like you can't
leave anything you're doing you're
you're getting growth from the account
but you're not making money from the
account right so you can't teach people
how to do the same thing you're doing
you can teach them how to grow but you
can't teach them how to turn that into
something that they can build money off
of so that becomes the next challenge is
like okay how do we then translate
growth on a on a platform into money so
that you're making money but then you
can also if you want choose to teach
people how to do the same thing as well
the easiest thing that comes to mind are
not the ones who are laughing ha haa but
the DMS so let's talk about the DMS what
are the top three things people are
asking you in the DMS advice uh how do I
get a job that allows you to move
overseas that's a big one right overseas
or to the demand to well mostly Dr but
yeah overseas but mostly Dr let's just
go Dr how do I get a job there cuz you
know wage earners there don't make a lot
and the people that I know that live
like I do in Dr they're making us
dollars or Canadian dollars in Dr like
they're making it remotely right like I
do with my other business how do I get a
job how do I get employed how do I make
money right that's one okay a lot of
real estate questions because I do a lot
of stuff on you know kind of the market
and real estate and what I see so
there's questions about real estate how
do I buy a house buy a house find a
management company is Airbnb a good
medium down there that sort of thing
yeah different real estate related
questions third one is what do you do to
make money that's probably the biggest
one like how are you making money maybe
that goes with the first one but no no
that's fine so the third one the third
one is not as helpful yet because you
need scale to do that because if
somebody doesn't have money it's hard to
build a business you need big scale to
make money off of people who don't have
money right it's a free content
advertising sponsorship Etc the first
one potentially can you can you help
people get high paying jobs in the in
the Dr in the Dr No Okay so that one's
then not a good fit I could teach them
how to get remote type work that they
can then move to Dr with but that not
not in the so your biggest short-term
opportunity and even for the next like
longterm is Real Estate
helping facilitate the move to the
Dr and partnering with all the people
around real estate so you take a cut for
making introductions not necessarily you
getting your own brokerage set up
although that might be a thing but you I
don't know what the laws are and the Dr
there's you don't need licensing or
anything like that yeah so to to partner
to create Jamie trusted
uh people that's the question like is
there I just did I did two posts one
last night with news like of the cycle
of of real estate then this morning it
just perfectly I said here's where I
wouldn't invest here's where I would
invest and that's blowing up people are
that's where my DMs are blowing up yes
but they're asking do you know about
this project you know about that project
I'm like no no I don't I don't I don't
that's fine so to know those people
would be and serving not you being the
real estate expert no top level
commentary but to have Jamie proved
people yeah that if I'm going to move to
the Dr I'm going to talk to your people
Y and they're they're knowledgeable
they're the experts maybe you bring them
on every now and then for a a topic that
might be a podcast yeah but you're
taking a cut of introductions that you
make or or a cut of their entire
business they're going to be
knowledgeable they're going to be
ethical they're going to treat people
the way that they're representing your
brand well I mean having work with you
you're you're ethical you're caring you
stay back you answer all questions like
you genuinely want people to win um
which is rarer in the business world and
rarer in real estate you know it's just
so transactional the great thing is
those people usually are not great at
marketing no they're not so the people
who are really knowledgeable and who
actually genuinely care about service
and helping usually are crappy marketers
y so you're going to do the marketing
for them you're you're
fulfilling their their time their deals
Etc and you take a cut of anything that
you bring in or potentially their whole
thing mhm the cut of their whole
business and whoever that works out so
you take 25% of everything that comes in
not the like how much they make what do
they make out of a deal you're taking
25% of whatever they make out of the
deal and you're going to keep passing
people through that's step one so
anybody who's moving to the Dr or
seriously considering moving to Dr buy
I've got you covered buying yeah sure
buying property setting up Airbnb
whatever I've got you covered you're
going to talk to whoever your your one
guy is two guys are three that's what I
mean that's what Bo does for me right
yeah yeah I partner with Bo we do a
revenue share in the business and I help
introduce him to people brilliant you
came in and say Bo is great if you came
in and say like Bo man that guy is like
I'd have a serious talk with Bo like
he's representing my brand right but I
have zero concerns with introducing bow
to people because he he deeply cares
about people's success and his clients
so people don't want to leave him so I'm
not I have no issues with referring
people off the bow and I talk to B once
a week and we go over clients and grow
in the business so same thing how do you
do that in the real estate world of
helping people whatever the commission
structure is fee structure is typically
discussion I've had recently like 20% of
the commission would come to me if I
were to partner with a realtor for
instance like hey I'm going to refer
everybody to you there's one guy that I
do trust he's a friend our families are
friendly our kids go to school together
so yeah 20% of that commission would be
would be mine okay so how do we get to
25 because you're bringing in for volume
right you're bringing in volume but also
like Americans we're we're you're
bringing in people with money yeah we're
not just selling local stuff like you're
bringing in higher net worth people who
then become ongoing if we're buying
rental properties it's not just one we
want to have let's start selling
Apartments let's start selling bigger
deals right and you get 25% of the
commission because they spend zero yeah
no they're spending zero on ads zero on
marketing zero on Flyers zero on right
like that's 25% that's worth 25% I get
it no 100% yeah right this is your back
to Kanye belief that you're bringing
that value which you are like you you
doing all that work is worth more than
it's worth more than 25% no I know the
belief isn't there that I bring value
the the it's the receptiveness it's the
ability to be a good receiver that
always blocks me at that point you know
like the the um yes I I get it like I
could I could fill up your bucket
realtor x with a bunch of referrals of
people that are serious are looking to
buy they're desperate so you already had
the conversation now you just say I need
25%
I this is what actually worth more I
need 25% yeah and if I don't bring you
people then there's no there's no harm
no F I'm going to bring you targeted
people yep all right so that's the
starting point that's starting now we're
set to make money right so like how much
is do you have a sense of how much a
commission is on some of these
properties I think it's the same
structure say 6% of a property that goes
for 300 Grand okay so like how many
deals can we pass through like but this
should be a sixf figure business to you
easily yeah yeah but quickly quickly
without even really trying to do much of
anything else that's that's the one like
it's sitting in a in a it's there's a
funnel there right like I can open that
funnel up flood it through and and
absolutely there's there's a business so
like that that and then whether you want
to stay with all the other other
projects you're doing or commit more
time to doing this like you already have
DMS right now that you can say just talk
to this guy like what's oh we won't say
his name just talk to this guy yeah and
he'll take care of you yeah yeah that's
immediate six figures in 2024 for you
yeah okay continued focus on real estate
then allows you to that could be a seven
figureure business to you and then you
bring on a couple agents because you're
going to fill up a pipeline your
marketing is going to do more than one
agent can handle so unless he's got
multiple agents with him right so that's
your seven figure business okay maybe
you hit seven figures next year maybe
yeah if you focus on it with belief and
focus for sure yeah like if you you may
not hit total seven figures but you
could be on the path for six figures a
month which then becomes seven figure
business yep right y uh and then into
the next year for sure seven figure
business from there you can kind of do
whatever you want to do right you know
like how much how much do you need to
make right I mean even now I mean with
the businesses that I do have I I do
well I really do I was actually
calculating last night like couple
hundred grand from this couple hundred
grand from that right like all these
different things they add up um for sure
so right but like they may not scale as
hard CU they need you to be there it's
it's requiring more time pumping energy
and and you like like it too you don't
hate the things you're doing but now you
get if you're making seven figures a
year doing this you get you have options
do you want to still keep this thing do
you want to cut that thing do you want
to join a mastermind to learn more do
you want to like you you you get to pick
right yeah when you're not a billionaire
but you're making seven figures American
living in the Dr you might as well be
right I mean doing well doing well
you're doing really well yeah but from
there you get the pick do you go all in
on real estate and build that to an8
figureure real estate business do you
look at the services around real estate
do you get do you do the same deal with
mortgage guys why not who your mortgage
guys yeah I don't have any yeah well not
yet take a cut on the mortgage right
they need a mortgage M where's the
mortgage going to come from are they
getting mortgage from their Bank in New
York or do they need to get a mortgage
locally yeah I don't know what are the
laws it's there in in locally in Dr yeah
so how do they do that they have no idea
yeah take a cut here's our team how
about the how about about the lawyer
who's signed out the contracts yeah
that's a great point you build this yeah
like you know let me plug you in here's
everything you need right around you all
in one spot all recommended by Jamie so
I built a house when I was uh after I
sold my business and whatever we built
the house from scratch and Mike Holmes
do you guys know Mike Holmes no Mike
Holmes is like a
Canadian uh he's he's a canadi he was a
Canadian TV guy I think he's still
around but he was really frustrated with
how the trades were ripping people off
and homeowners don't know the difference
cuz they're like I don't know my light
is broken oh that's $88,000 okay like
they don't know and also building things
like bare minimum the code or under code
where it's like you should be doing like
you should be proud of your work so he
built his brand on that so when we built
a home he had a company where it's all
his his recommended people he doesn't do
anything you never meet my comes but
it's run through his company you meet a
project manager through his company and
then all of the subs are people that he
recommends so you're you're taking the
mikee Holmes name and brand it's the
same thing with you you don't have to
meet them and do everything it's just
it's the Jamie
grber brand people that use I say go use
this lawyer what do I know I'm living in
Toronto how do I know which lawyer to
pick I don't know yeah I'm going to get
ripped off so I'd even pay a premium to
go with your guy and I'm happy knowing
that you're going to get paid part of it
because it's your guy and I'm not going
to get screwed because if I have a
problem I'm going to talk to Jamie MH so
you take a cut of all of these
businesses
so just within mortgage real estate and
um the legal side you have you have your
eight figure business making
recommendations and referrals provided
you keep up on the marketing of creating
content and getting interest and hitting
DMS and all this stuff sure right we do
go beyond that well what else do people
need when they come you know are they
coming because they have their own
business are they coming because they
need property manage managers for airb
they need to yeah I've got a management
company yeah yeah like all of these
things you're doing it done for you do
they need help with the listings to put
it up on their BNB you could help with
that yeah right like it's all it's all
still within our world we could go big
here because there's really no MLS uh
centralized real estate system in the
country so it's like where do I go to
look at all the listings like broker to
broker to broker to broker right like so
to have something centralized as uh a
technology solution you have the best
buyers you have people coming from
America with bigger budgets you have the
best buyers Y and maybe that's enough
you know the next step up would be okay
where are they all going to work if
they're all you got a bunch of
entrepreneurs coming do you create an
incubator you know instead of now just
taking a cut of these businesses do you
create your own startups and have equity
in the whole company what else do they
need it's like and then now you're
you're Adventure capitalist do I stay
focused in on Instagram then for all of
this I was going to expand to YouTube I
would put whatever you do on Instagram
on YouTube shorts for sure well I do
that but as far as as far as building
longer form content on YouTube the long
form is education yeah educational and
uh for a lot of people a different
audience like it's a percentage of your
phone is blowing up with 50 DMS or
whatever but it's still a percentage a
small percentage of how many people are
looking at your content if you're
getting 880,000 views a day or 100,000
views a day all in or whatever you're
getting and you're getting 50 DMS that's
a tiny percentage it's a lot to handle
but it's it's more in a day I me like in
the last hour about 50 but yeah a few
hundred still it's a percentage of your
total numbers right so it's fine like
that's what you want you want you want
to guide people to free resources where
you can make
videos and then for the people who
actually wanted who are more serious
about it like how do I get a job in a Dr
that's a video because you can't help
them do that right can can you get me a
high paying job NOP no I can't the whole
like can I move there and get a job back
in America and maybe but those are not
going to be ideal clients for you to
work with so for those people you make
free content and you guide people
towards it and you could do longer form
content and you could be talking head
educational make 10- minute plus videos
the same topics you're doing on
Instagram but just longer form y you
could do long form
podcasts if you wanted to help you go
your business you do it with the people
who you are partnering with so you're
going to partner with Sally or I don't
know who whatever Spanish name Sally
she's going to be the person you're
investing into and she's the real estate
expert then you sit down and you do a
podcast talking about real estate Trends
and you're asking her questions like I
love Sally because she is she's my go-to
person for all things real estate here
in the Dominican Republic and she's also
ethical and she works with expats and
all this stuff and I love her and she
represents the brand and we're going to
talk about all the things you need to
think about before you buy a home here
in Dominican and that video won't pop
and get a million views but the people
who are watching it are the right people
yeah sure and leads to
sales leads to people calling her
because of what you created yeah so
that's where it's like okay we're less
concerned about pure numbers and reach
and more concerned about the right
people watching so that you are making
money from it okay at some point in all
of
this you need to figure out the whole
quit your job and Do Your Own Thing
passion that you have to help
people will need to be birthed you know
that will need to come out oh and I are
working on that now so we're launching a
uh uh Audio Only podcast in January on
that called holy quit great name um case
studies of people that have done you
know made the leap tactical tips that
kind of so I wouldn't do anything Audio
Only You Do video too of course you're
making you're spending time doing it
anyway make a video yeah why would you
not make a video only because I have the
other video podcast where it feels like
a bandwidth thing at a certain point but
yeah what's the bandwidth thing it's
still you making content just video
optimization YouTube thumbnails all that
stuff feels like a lot more work than
just hey here's an audio version vers so
the idea is then don't do don't put in
that work like don't optimize it yeah
cuz the work is you sitting down and
making the content so even if you throw
up unoptimized content it's still
probably going to be the best stuff
about how to move to the Dr on YouTube
that will still generate leads for you
more than an audio only podcast fair
enough and then you can always go back
and add a thumbnail and add better
titles and optimize it later that's a
good point okay so I think you've got
the these two Brands and the first one
is the one that makes you a ton of
money and you have your how much you
want you want to it's like a 7 you might
not want to build an figure business you
know like my current businesses or
whatever run on me being actively
involved running you know meetings the
whole night um if I if I Sunset that and
this becomes the replacement income and
I don't have to do this stuff anymore as
an example or if I want to systematize
my way out and let those run and take
less that's fine I've got literally a
hey you're a good connector and you make
money simply by being a good connector
and a good Market creating content
correct yep so that makes sense that's
whatever you said I can go to seven
figures eight figures whatever it is you
want to stop I can drive that to
wherever I wanted to go and um okay
while the other brand is not about not
about the Dominican but about how to
quit your job and create your own and
whether that's you teaching whether
that's you interviewing people or both
yeah or both whatever and and it doesn't
have to be it doesn't have to pay you
anything yet like longer term that's a
much bigger Global
brand right like how many people in the
world want to move to Dominican that's a
that's a piece of a piece of a piece
right how many people want to quit their
job and do their own like everybody
right so longer term it's a much bigger
brand much bigger opportunity if you
want a book deal you want speaking gigs
you want brand deals like that's the
play yeah that's the million plus
subscribers that we're going after yeah
but it's a journey to get there when you
say other brand so am I separating these
completely so I've got my Instagram
account which is me yeah the Jamie grber
and then I build a YouTube channel which
is my current YouTube channel Jamie
grber right and I'm just talking about
that move and building trust and and and
um Affinity with that brand about hey
those of you that want to live in
Paradise live down here in Dr or have a
vacation property or whatever there it
is but this other stuff is it a separate
YouTube channel a separate Instagram
yeah they're both different uh and you
don't even need to rush to make the
personal one yet make the personal one
what I'm sorry so I think the personal
one the Jamie grber brand is the holy
quit got it holy quit is a show within
the Jamie grber brand yep that's the
podcast that's the interview whatever
this where I struggle is is like the
Synergy of the but go ahead I'm sorry
yeah so so holy quit lives under Jamie
grber what is Jamie grber though Jamie
grber is its own YouTube channel its own
website what's on it
how to quit your job so on my on the
Jamie grber YouTube channel how to quit
your job it's all about how to quit your
job and start your own business okay
that's your that's your deep passion
that is a Jamie grber brand got it holy
quit is a show under the Jamie grber
brand okay there will be other
shows
yep long form short form I Tri of
millionaires I have you know like these
other shows right yeah all under like
the whole point of the Jimmy G brand is
I'm I'm the guy to help you if you're
pass about something and you want to
quit your job and take a chance like I
want to I'm that guy that's Jamie grber
y you don't have to worry about building
that guy yet I mean you kind of are that
guy behind the scenes for a lot of
people just one-on-one small events
talking to people you've helped
countless people with advice and they've
seen Real Results right but but globally
or across America or whatever like they
don't know you yet right you don't have
to be in a rush to build that brand
that's your Forever thing Dominican
Republic brand doesn't even have to
necessarily be your name like it's
whatever you said move the paradise
you're the you're the move the paradise
guy which isn't under Jamie guber it's
you're the move to Paradise guy or
Rebrand the Instagram yeah and it
doesn't have to happen right now no
right but Jamie Gruber the man is this
bigger play bigger branding play the
bigger Financial play especially
shortterm is Dominican So you you're the
move the paradise guy you're the move
the Dominican guy all right just getting
tactical so I've got this Channel or
this this uh uh Instagram account with
50,000 Subs uh
followers that is me m at some point
whatever that is that becomes you know
Paradise guy Y and I leave that yeah it
becomes move to the Dr so all of the
platforms that that go forward for Jamie
Gruber are brand new from the start okay
got it that's what I want to make sure I
was hearing that right so so leave this
effort over here this Dominican effort
leave that all there that's that's
that's the audience that found me that's
the audience I'm serving there leave it
there build it there build a YouTube
with it so right y um and I've got all
of that to provide value and the
monetization plan with that without
having to take a dollar from anybody to
sell something to them is let me connect
you to my my trusted advisor group of
everything you need to buy property here
y because it's all about the real estate
I could do educational content on the
real estate I could do tours of real
estate I can do all of that right here's
what's important and you need somebody
to buy and to and to manage to man
exactly y full service full stack
everything is done under that so I
figure out the right timing for pivoting
that that uh the brand over to that
picture of me with a palm tree coming
out of my head or whatever yeah I it
could be more fun but like now it's very
clear you are the move to Dominican guy
I get the most questions around that for
sure yeah that's what your content's
about yeah that's the rush not
necessarily in terms of The Branding
redo but in terms of the focused effort
on monetization
so then this second podcast on the quit
side the Jamie grber core brand or
whatever am I getting too far ahead of
my skis and launching that if you have
extra bandwidth if you have extra time
if it's fun if it's like burning a hole
in your soul then go do it okay but it
kind of is it's not even close on the
size of opportunity it's not if you're
only looking at it strategically
immediate opportunity you mean yes right
even longer term opportunity
because you doing that show while you're
also running these other businesses
while you're also doing like you need
to make money inside this business ASAP
to get out of these other businesses to
then hire team to help you scale this so
then you can scale team on the other
side so you doing everything like in
these little bits means nothing gets
done well true where if you can maximize
and do well the thing that makes you
money then you hire your team to help
you do everything else so your ability
to make holy quit pop is negligible
right now it's you fumbling around doing
Audio Only
I don't know why either because I have a
production company and we are we're very
profitable and that profit can be turned
into the team numbers we have three or
four people on the team team members
needed for us to for us to create the
entirety of like to your point that's
one thing I give myself credit for in
the last year the businesses that I have
I've gotten out of backend operations on
so I'm I'm only face I'm only forward
facing which is what I'm good at and
what I enjoy so they're kind of there
the they're the business sustains uh
staff Chief Operating person Chief
systems person you know an
administrative staff and all that stuff
to run all the stuff dayto day so I just
have to show up which is kind of cool
like just be a face be present be all of
that so now it's yeah to your
point it's get this get these
relationships down because that's going
to take some work to vet the people the
right people to really make that you
know like it's not it's all opportunity
cost yeah so doing that show again
unless it's burning I wouldn't even
treat it as this is not a business
opportunity this is your charity yeah
this is like you want to go see quit
yeah yeah it's it's charity work it
feels a different bucket cuz if you look
at it from a business perspective
they're not even close to being equal
right so that if this has taken time
away from you building the real estate
thing it's not a it's not a smart move
build the real estate thing got it Go
build the relationships you have people
dming you already who can line up for
deals that makes sense you'll make
dollars right away you've already done
the hardest work which is building the
audience yeah go make your seven figure
business off of that and then hire team
and the other things and do whatever you
want with holy quit or the whole Jamie
grber brand got it easy enough I always
talk about having a long-term Vision
five-year Vision whatever that might be
and then working your way back to
today's goals to achieve that Vision am
I thinking too far out in that kind of
model like what do you do yeah I've
become less a fan of fivey year goals or
10 year
goals
because you know how old are you now 45
45 cuz I'm 43 so 45 so Jamie at
35 what degree of accuracy do you think
you're predicting
where where you are now zero what were
you doing at 35 yeah I was executive
with an insurance company yeah now
you're even even two years ago yeah
could you imagine that you're going all
in on Dr content and building that I
wouldn't think I flew from pakana to
Toronto to hang out with a a huge
YouTuber if you couldn't imagine being
here what makes you think that you know
we going to be at 55 yeah that's fair no
idea but do you have to establish that
North Star well that's not a North star
a 10 your goal is not a North star okay
your North Star is your mission the
mission is to help people get out of
their jobs because from knowing you from
all of our interactions that is the most
consistent thing that is always I call
it my mission I always say to inspire
and motivate others to live their best
life which yeah but even within their
best life like it's specifically around
you love helping new entrepreneurs get
started get off the ground believe in
themselves not go from Seven figures to
eight figures but like like get their
first six figures put your job right
that's like your heart is there 100%
that will never change and so the
technology might change YouTube and then
VR or ar or hologram or whatever but
you're going to be 120 years old and
some old age home beaming into people's
living rooms telling them to go for
it you're only 90 that's the North Star
right yeah you're just getting
started you're young and I'm 120 still
doing this your teeth fall out yeah it's
great
exactly so that's the
Northstar but the how will change
constantly so there's nothing
necessarily wrong with having a
five-year goal or 10 year goal just
expect that if you're actually growing a
year or two in you need to you need to
jump to go do something else well that's
what this is and that's what's
interesting about this whole this whole
experience so Bo and I are coaching on
this he's coaching me on building the
brand and he got me really really dialed
into like my explicit my implicit value
statement for whatever a audience I'm
trying to build and the the if I were to
land the plane the way I wanted to land
the plane it would have been this is the
guy who quits his job and um uh whatever
moves abroad or or lives the way he
wants to live right like as an expat
maybe even that maybe that's the niche
like quit your job and live wherever you
want to live or travel the world right
that would have been the so as I start
to build content I I over index on spe
specificity in the Dominican Republic he
actually tells me about 2 days before my
my my following starts to pop you're a
little too Niche if your goal is to be
more the xack guy two days later boom it
blows up and it's mostly people that are
interested in the Dominican Republic so
his advice was the universe delivered
you this audience serve it right first
off do you agree with that I think with
the the whole expat thing
you're trying to put your ass on two
horses no no I'm I'm off of it now yeah
yeah no I think I think you go hardcore
Dominican and build up around that cuz
that's like a happy mistake and then the
other side is just how to quit your job
and and start your own business yeah
without being an expat cuz dude if
somebody came to you and i' I've met
them I've met people who you helped who
have zero interest in being an expat and
traveling and setting up in wherever and
being nomadic and you love helping them
like that's not the core the traveling
is not the core part of you this is me
trying to Frankenstein it all together
yeah it's like your ass on two horses
like don't don't don't try to mix them
they're two separate Brands yeah and
that's your brand for life and the and
the real estate one is the one that will
help generate the income to pay for the
brand for Life yeah yeah yeah that makes
sense that makes perfect sense it is
like I said happy mistake because I I
actually really enjoy I mean I'm I'm
there so studying what's happening you
know I want to do some men on the street
stuff because a lot of people recognize
me now so if I they recognize I pull out
the lab mic and what do you do here how
do you make money here like how are you
living here as an right like to deliver
that value I really enjoy the the DMs I
I enjoy the interaction so it's so like
that that man on the street is good
content that's a happy accident again if
you happen to be seeing somebody at the
grocery store or whatever um if you want
to set up intentional podcasts then it's
the people that you partnered with or
could be some of your clients that
you've worked with like here's Evan he
just he just bought with us moving to
the Dominic uh and whatever you want to
tell my story as to why I'm moving why
not a sales pitch as to like and you got
to work with Jamie although I'm probably
going to say that cuz I love you right I
get it yeah right but me telling my
story makes makes the viewer who's
thinking about becoming an expat be like
huh Okay evan did it he has this kind of
business okay maybe I can do it too or
if I'm just doing as an investor to buy
Airbnb properties and now you set me up
full service management company now I
have five apartment buildings and you're
airb being the whole thing for me I'm
just taking a cut it's like man I when I
started with Jamie I was here and now
I'm here and I'm just a lawyer in
Toronto or whatever more of those
examples that you share like that's a
good long form show to have as opposed
to just interviewing a local Dr business
owner or something yeah that's awesome
now that's what I was going to do so
that's really good um last question on
this I view part of the value
proposition I have as being able to
display and show what's happening so I
could picture myself doing longer form
content you know whatever uh here's the
five items all CU I I had this people on
Instagram like can you get this can you
get this can you get this at a grocery
store down there that just don't know so
to go to like five different grocery
stores record it all buy them all and
then show the receipts at the end and
say yeah you can and here's the cheapest
place that kind of stuff like showing
life on the ground is that a good
strategy bad strategy too much work is
it getting me off task you think about
like this channel is designed to bring
ideal clients to hire you and all your
real estate services so does the content
align line with that or not I don't know
that's what I'm wondering like well
anything that is the cheapest is not
you're going to be it's not going to be
ideal clients you don't want the people
who are looking for the cheapest of
anything the best option the place with
the most like that has all the high-end
stuff might be a better I don't know
enough about the Dr but Puerto Rico I
have a bunch of friends that move the
puer Americans move to Puerto Rico for
tax reasons and all that and there's the
pros of it being on the beach and the
tax benefits and all that but the
downside of the storms knock out the
internet you can't get access there's no
Whole Foods there's no you know easy
access to the Creature Comforts that
you're used to so what would my hacks be
like is there Whole Foods in the in the
Dr essentially yeah it's called it's
called n now but same thing okay but so
like like that's who we want to Target
yeah people who are worried that there's
no Whole Foods I'm not looking for the
cheapest I'm looking for the Whole Foods
how do I get Whole Foods I did a story
once just walking into a grocery store
and it was like for for people that
aren't Dominican like that's what a grow
I think they think everything's a bodega
everything's just like a little yeah
yeah like hole in the wall some guy
behind a c behind a you know bulletproof
glass and there's a piece of lettuce and
a you know whatever but so so what do I
get that's new yeah like the beaches and
the whatever like the culture and the
vibe what do I get that's new what are
some fun things that you love to do you
love to get a massage every week and it
cost you 20 bucks or I don't know
whatever the thing 60 but I do at B yeah
what whatever whatever is new that I
can't get yeah and then what how do I
replace what I'm used to so I'm not
taking a step back so go high end higher
end cuz that's who we want good this is
good because the downside of me being so
engaged with the people that are
following me right now like I again I I
I take a lot of time answering DMS
commenting on every comment and all of
that stuff is I see the I see the
negative comments too and the negative
comments if there's one it's you know
you're colonizing outpricing it people
like you are colonizing outpricing the
the the market for you know regular
folks down there who make $500 a month
um you know if I do a post about the
fact that we have full-time house care
home care for everything we don't do
laundry we don't do we don't cook we
don't clean everything is taken care of
s days a week $800 a month it's
absolutely insane to me it's amazing I
love that benefit yeah but I see the
detractors in like you know a you slave
labor and it's like and I know that's
not true but I tend to pull off the
accelerator a little bit in it to avoid
offending but I have to ignore those
voices and go to the high end because
most people 90% are like this is great
this is awesome to know thank you yeah
so instead of making a post on like how
to find the cheapest banana yeah right
you're saying like how do I replace
whole there's no Whole Foods on the
island so here's what you do instead and
it's basically the same stuff yeah
you're looking for your blank so like is
there Starbucks in Dominican yeah
there's just there in the city and we
just built one in in Pana just got the
first one there's two Starbucks here
guys there's Starbucks in right I didn't
know that yeah right so like any of
those things so I get I can get what I'm
used to how fast is the internet regular
speed 240 upload test here's my internet
people say that the island internet
sucks look at mine here it is yeah like
oh the internet's that good it's private
electric so there's no power outages all
that stuff right that's all great like
these are all the concerns so I want the
I want the upside of the location and
the cost of living and all this stuff
but I don't want all the downside how's
the healthcare what if I need to get a
surgery I've done stuff on that like
that kind of stuff is the things people
care about no you're right like the
stuff that really gets people interested
like my son had Denay fever I don't know
if you know what that is but it's a
mosquito born uh virus and uh we had to
hospitalize them two nights the hospital
room was incredible beautiful Hospital
hital is private um meaning it's a
private hospital and if you could afford
insurance and all that then you get the
best health care but at the end of it we
paid 44 bucks for two nights of
hospitalization great now you can sell
insurance too you know it's funny my
insurance I tagged them because people
were like what insurance they have what
insurance they have what insurance I
tagged them probably 80 times and they
never they never reped but I was
thinking like oh this might be a way
that I
can well I could help I could monetize
the relationship get a sponsored post or
something but I got to think big post
yeah I got to think bigger than that
they pay for results like you're going
to pump all of these deals and if that
company sucks like but like don't tag
them and hope that they see it and then
respond go knock on their door and say
I'm Jamie grouper look you see all these
people ask me about insurance can we
strike up a deal yeah like you're great
at that yeah that's just old school
sales and talking to people yeah or you
talk to your current you do a real
estate deal or a a legal deal like they
all have contacts too hey I'm trying to
do something in real in insurance too
who do you deal with
yeah because if they're going to move
here they're going to the agent the
whomever right that's a great that's a
great post it's like hey if you
something happens the Dr Healthcare is
actually state-of-the-art like look this
is a hospital we're not in Shacks or
anything here like people think Canada
is like oh where are the igloos and like
the snow and everything guys we're like
I saw three igloo out yeah right it's
like there's there's LA and New York and
then Toronto we're bigger than every
other City you've got in the US Chicago
We're bigger than Chicago are you yeah
media Market wise You're Number Four I
looked at up up media Market what is
that like just the media I don't know
like the the New York is the largest
media Market la Chicago Toronto so great
but population wise like we're bigger
than Chicago We're bigger than Dallas
we're bigger than Houston we're bigger
than Philly right yeah but just it's a
perception and so people come here it's
like oh where's the snow like wow
there's so many people there like
skyscrapers are you kidding me right but
that's fine and it's probably even worse
thinking about the Dr it is it is yeah
third world that's what they think third
world so then you go and you show off
the state-of-the-art hospital and that
if you get the right Insurance it only
cost you 44 bucks a night or whatever
MH and here's the insurance guy go talk
to him and we have a team I'll help you
yeah yeah I like that I didn't think in
those terms okay can I get a car is
there a car dealership like what am I if
I'm coming in and I want a rental like
am I getting some crappy car how do how
do I deal with my car do I have to like
boat them
over I did a bit on that I did a a thing
on that but yeah no it's a great
question how much is a private chef yeah
all of the services you get for 800 a
month what does it include if I wanted
somebody to to if I want a private Chef
what would that cost me right so it's
like how do I what are the upsides all
the things that I can gain that I'm
thinking about but then also like the
full service maintenance I wasn't
thinking about I'm thinking beaches I'm
thinking WEA not oh you get 800 bucks
for the whole house to be maintained by
a team right that's I wasn't thinking
about now I am because you're telling me
and then how do I replace the things
that I feel I'm going to miss how's the
school how's the education system yeah
yeah
I get that question is it on par yeah
what's the best school are the schools
private yeah my kids are in private
school it's amazing they they go they
yoga they go to the beach every week
with them they have deal with the school
CrossFit on Thursdays how much how much
is the private school uh 15 grand a year
great take a cut yeah I want to bring
students in for you y I want 25% it's a
great idea because there are people a
lot of people are asking about that like
ah are School are the schools up to
Snuff yeah well some of the schools
aren't like and you just be honest
review like here some of these schools
aren't just like in the US some schools
are great and some schools are crap I
always go with that people like what
about crime I'm like can find crime in
Chicago depends on the neighborhood yeah
any of those things like this if the
school is 15K a year go and ask for a
cut like I'll do all the marketing for
you I'm going to send people in if
somebody signs up I want
25% see what they say okay but that's
the content to make more than where to
find the cheapest banana or can of tuna
or whatever I didn't make it it wasn't
like that like the cheapest Nutella
people like Nutella down there so that's
one of them but bananas yeah bananas
well but but knowing that you can get
Nutella is great like can I get Nutella
there that's what I mean that's when you
said that that's what triggered for me
it's like the the types of products you
can get and where you can get them right
like it's not a matter of like because
you're right like gas prices if you're
above a certain socioeconomic status
whether gas prices are four or $5 a
gallon it's like so I spend 60 or $70
when I go to the pump like you don't
want to be the guy finding the cheapest
gas price right right right right if you
go to this guy and he's 18 miles out but
you're going to get a cent off it's like
that's not who you want to be attracting
okay now this makes this all makes sense
I appreciate that tax structure if I'm
going to come and start a business or if
I'm going to do my Airbnb business do I
need to set up a corporation in the Dr
is it more tax advantageous to do it
like that or not do I have my place in
Canada my company like I don't know like
all these questions that most people may
not ask or worry about but your ideal
people would be yeah and you can
sprinkle in your fun and man on the
street and all the other stuff as well
but like when you're being strategic
about content we want to be attracting
the right people because highend yeah we
want to turn you know if you have
100,000 people watch the videos we want
to be turned that into 5,000 DMS that
are coming in and you're hiring somebody
to like funnel to the right places plus
free stuff you know like all the stuff
that you can't make uh margin on you
funnel them somewhere for somebody says
how do I find a job or whatever like
jobs make a video on that like jobs are
not easy to get and they don't they
don't pay very much your best bet is to
have a a job remote from the US get paid
in US Dollars and just live there MH if
you want to find remote jobs here are
some ideas for you okay and you just
send people to those links and resources
but you don't want to then make 20
videos about how to find a job in the
Dominican because somebody is trying to
find a job they're not going to be your
ideal client right right right right
right yeah okay man that makes sense
I've got a lot of homework to do
but I get the point that you know the
the Dr stuff like that's the that's the
immediate there's like I already have
that attention I already have that trust
I'm very very passionate and authentic
about wanting that maintaining that
right so um to find the developers
because a lot of people a lot of people
are asking right now like do you know
about this project this developer it's
like I don't here's a developer I trust
here's one that I've seen do the work
I've seen let me get you in touch with
them or or partner with the developer
and say I'll I'll that's what I mean
I'll sell you yeah well but that have
you heard about the developer reach out
to the developer yeah now you now you've
heard about them right is it a good
project oh oh oh yeah true instead of
diverting them to another project maybe
you make a deal with this guy yeah or
maybe there's warning signs like no no
no don't trust the developer because
like he's building on quicksand the
whole thing is going to fall apart yeah
and if your real estate team is kind of
helping you dissect the pro it shouldn't
be you no no no right I right people
saying no yes no all that Jamie G team
yeah okay there's a building close to
here that I almost moved into it looks
sleek it's like emerald green it's super
it's like awesome it was coming up all
the Interiors all the specs were
beautiful and my real estate agent is
like that this is like they're doing on
the cheap is a piece of crap building I
would never buy anything here okay I'm
not buying anything here because Mark
told me not to buy there yeah even
though it looks sick sure right because
I trust Mark what do I know about
highrises in real estate I want to spend
the time to research and learn all that
stuff that's fair that's fair especially
if it's in a different country yeah no
no I get it I get it completely there's
a lot of different things my brain my
brain is going to a lot of different
areas right now so you've done the
hardest thing which is build an audience
build the audience that's what all of
these guys are trying to do yeah the
real estate and the mortgage and that's
the connection I've ever made been I've
always done a nice job of building an
audience varying degrees obviously but
I've always been able to do that when I
got into multif family uh investing in
Michigan I built this Meetup that Meetup
scaled quickly we had thousands of
people in the Facebook group highly
engaged because I love doing that I love
building Community right and then I got
some deals from it Clos on a 16 unit
close on a 22 unit all from members of
that group bringing the deals right so I
didn't make anything off of the
community if you will but all of a
sudden we had 21 chapters of this group
with 16 177,000 members in these
combined groups you know I had uh a
voice in that specific niche in multif
family but I've never been able to take
that and and well I shouldn't say never
been I haven't been able to take the
loow hanging fruit connection of well if
you got this audience and they need this
give them that instead I partnered with
like go abundance and built a community
with them and it grows and scales and my
attention the attention I'm able to gain
does help help uh build that um but it's
theirs at the end of the day 60% of it
anyway right like I own 40% of it so so
to take like you said yeah you built
this attention here there's a connection
I've I don't I'm never comfortable
making on monetizing that you know yeah
but it's like
you're providing services that they want
that's like desperately that's like not
monetizing well your clients are are
paying nothing like you're not saying
hey I'll make an introduction if you pay
me $5,000 that's not monetizing not in
the way that I'm thinking about
monetizing not in the mental block of
monetizing and the people who are in the
Dr Who have these businesses need more
clients yeah you're feeling a need for
them so it's a B2B play not a b Toc
right he's like you only need five
people or whoever that you're partnering
up with here to say hey I'm going to
make a deal with you I'm going to bring
in people I want 25% of the revenue that
generates do you want to do this or not
yeah it's a pretty easy I like it man
pretty easy yes that's good and then the
clients pay you nothing it's like how
all the insurance like you're not paying
the insurance brokers anything they take
it from the insurance companies it's the
best most effective way to take this
attention and divert it people have a
need they desperately need it those that
serve those people pay me not the people
that I'm serving yeah you fell into this
opportunity yeah I did yeah that happens
to also be something that you're good at
building relationships and be able to
convert that you understand business you
know you're not just oh I don't know I'm
some influencer and I don't know how to
do anything right like you have a you
know what these guys but there's a a
confidence or a a a block a limiting
belief whatever it might be that's
preventing me from from yeah so my my
strategy structure was okay I've got
this attention now convert that
attention over to a a platform like a
podcast where I can show reach to
sponsors and then make money from the
sponsor so I'm gonna I'm going to
commoditize the attention and divert it
but it's so it's clunky no that's way
too small for the Dr that's too small
that's your long-term jimy right but
that's that's my passion play but for
this yeah I mean I could I could on
autopilot add value deliver deliver to
those that need it the right people the
trusted people that that um pay me and I
don't do anything yeah so I could take
that and lean it to my passion where I
really want to help more broadly than
just moving to the Dr so did we
eliminate that limiting block there yeah
yeah yeah no we did we did honestly
great I think it's great let me ask you
since I have you what are you working on
next what's your big next big thing
you've got this four million person
YouTube account you've got your reach
you've got your audience you have done
what you're telling me to do in that
you've you know created uh connections
with people like Bo within your brand
that you can help serve others so like
what's next for an EV when you're at
your level what are you thinking about
next I'm passionate about about trying
to get legendary content out to the
world so we were talking about this
downstairs at the coffee shop but we're
partnering with people who know the
people who own legendary content so we
just partner with the guy who did the
last interview with Jim ran last video
ever done with him and so we partner
with him we put up on a YouTube channel
we do a revenue split with him for the
content um we're partnering with Diana
Nale who's Earl night and Gale's wife
partner with a bunch of people who
basically have access to Legendary
content usually people who have passed
who don't have a YouTube channel and the
family don't know what to do they're not
marketers they don't know what to do
with the content they maintain the IP
rights over it and we take it and make
it great for YouTube whether it's video
or audio that we turn into a video and
split the revenue with them so yeah I'm
just I'm excited I I've wanted to ask
you this I get this question a lot about
quitting the job the question is often
uh some a question statement I don't
know what I would do outside of this job
I make two three 400 Grand like I I I
have no idea what I what I could even do
and these are usually 40ish year old
people 35 to 45 let's say some older
some younger and my question is always
what do you love doing I always ask that
question and then they sit there and
think about it and I always say to them
at that moment it's like 99 out of 100
times they'll say you're asking yourself
a different question than I just asked
you and they'll say what do you mean I
said I asked you what do you love doing
and I think what you're asking yourself
likely right now is what do I love doing
that I could see a path to monetization
that's not what I ask what do you love
doing right because I think in that
answer there's the potential for a
business but people people struggle to
to see that I think you're an example
tell me if I'm wrong on this you love
consuming
content yes okay so you've taken
consuming content as Gary ve says it
about you right like you DJ that content
out in a different way taking on these
Legacy clients this Legacy content that
you're able to then DJ out to the world
or whatever so
help me further that message a bit
because like you said with me like hey
you enjoy talking about you know
whatever about Dr about about Dominican
Republic or or uh quitting the job which
has made me money doing it just talking
about quitting my job and it wasn't why
I quit my I didn't quit my job to then
say yeah I'm going to quit my job so I
can show you how to do it it just became
something that became in demand and I
was able to monetize it to the extent
that I have been able to tell me where
my advice is wrong right how would you
approach that because I feel like you're
the you're the The Shining Star of a
simple answer like I like watching
YouTube like how's that going to make me
money well you like watching YouTube or
you like watching content and then you
recreate that content in a way that's
effective for others is that the right
question is that the right C what I just
said to somebody from your perspective
what what do you love doing you're
asking yourself the wrong question don't
worry about monetization just what do
you love doing is that the right core
question do you think to start somebody
down the path of figuring their way out
of a situation that they want to be in
well you know I don't know that you I
don't know there's one right question
right just like like the fact that
they're starting down the path is
already a win because the path is messy
and windy maybe better said like how
would you how would you approach that
person for me it depends if I'm doing
one-on-one or if I'm doing a group
setting because in a group setting you
need a lot more structure yeah with
oneon-one when I came and did the speech
at go abundance is like I think I talk
for a little bit but I want it to be Q&A
and then I just help people one out a
time help people and and hopefully the
others learn through the helping was
like oh how did you know to they talk
about it to this day so yeah well great
well there was a great group yeah uh but
it's like customized advice for the
person so when I'm talking to
somebody there's no template because
what I'm trying to do when I'm at my
best I'm talking to them and disarming
them and just asking questions but in a
in a curious non non-judgmental way
where as soon as you ask a question like
that they're there and it's great that
you call it out like you're you're
answering it wrong because there's
pressure pressure I want people to be
pressureless cuz that's when they truly
come out so I never asked you Jamie what
do you really love doing I know that you
love helping people get started like
that's what you do and I know that it's
not helping them get started to so they
can go live abroad how do I know that
well because I've hung out with you and
I don't remember any specific question
that like I asked you to make that
happen so when you're dealing oneon-one
settings I would rather I'd rather just
talk about whatever they want to talk
about cuz in there's patterns that will
keep coming up whenever I'm coaching
somebody I'm asking asking asking asking
and seemingly like where is this even
going and then it switched to coaching
because once I got the answer okay now
we're going to move but it's almost
never from a direct question like that
where I'm trying to force a path you're
trying to force a path where you can
find out that question from the answer
to that question from a lot of different
ways of just getting them to talk about
like what were you doing this weekend
and you're looking for moments where
they're coming alive and you're just
being curious about them because in that
Curiosity something will great pop up
like yeah I was researching uh how to do
Airbnb like oh that's cool how come not
even giv them guidance yet because as
soon as you flip the coaching mode walls
come up even if they even if they bought
in no that's true they get defensive and
so now it's hard now you have to then
Tear Down the Walls to get the
information you need to to do the
coaching so I'd rather start off
completely disarmed and I'm asking
questions until I
find I'm just genuinely curious so it
doesn't always follow the same path I'm
curious about this person and I'm trying
to find the right way in before I go to
coaching mode because once I get to
coaching mode walls come up but I have
my answer so now we're g to we're going
to make some progress so that I would do
in a group setting if I took your group
at go abundance and it's like okay
here's how you find your passion okay
well that kind of question because it
because I can't go go one at a time
right for all of you right so if you're
doing a group you're doing a book you're
doing a speech you're doing a video
you're doing something that's group
where there's no direct one-on-one
feedback then you have to be a little
templated and and formula and you'll
still help people but if you're if
you're doing one-on-one
coaching I think the best one-on-one
coach is what are you essentially doing
your my goal isn't to help you uh do
what I would
do I think like some men tell you well
here's what I would do in your shoes
here's what I would do but you don't
want to do what you know what I would do
you got to do what you should do so a
great mentor in my perspective tells you
what you should do but knowing what I
know I know more than you about some
things so it's me telling you what you
should do knowing you but knowing the
information that I know right so I don't
want to do any of that I don't want to
start a real estate business in
Dominican Republic and make all these
deals like that's not someone tells me
to do that like you're an idiot that not
it's not going to work for me but it's
like perfect for you so it's what you
should do in knowing what I know and so
if you're going to help people through
this process of quitting their job and
starting their own
business um I think you can be much more
calculated with uh like you're you're
using the same knife for everything and
it's a good knife it's a great
question but you already have to disarm
them as so you're you're answering it
wrong where you should even know you
should know the answer to that question
before even diving into anything because
you've you've had conversation with
great answer it's something I talk about
with others it's like you can see it you
can see it when somebody else points it
out in you but it's always like just be
in service just be in service to right
and that's essentially what you're
saying like I'm I'm setting up an Aha
and I'm right meaning like I'm right as
far as like what's gonna happen next
like I can call it cool but it does it
makes you feel like this guy's just like
you know back off right whereas whereas
what you're doing is being in service
listening truly curious and even if they
ask for it the walls still come up
because now they don't want to be it's
not that you're attacking them but it's
just a natural resistance a feeling
right that you have so if you say what
do you want to do and now I'm stressing
out like what do I want to do oh my God
now I'm stressed out already you're not
going to make the best you're not going
to get the best answers from being
stressed out yeah and then now you're
telling me you're thinking about it
wrong oh my God now I'm thinking about
it wrong Jesus Christ I'm really
stressed out
and I'm worried about like what is my
answer I don't have an answer I don't
want him to think like I'm an idiot that
I don't have an answer even if I know
you and I love you and all those reports
been built up you're putting me in a
state of
stress and I don't think you get the
best results from that you still get
results so guess there's no one way and
I think that works I agree with you
though but I think if you're if you have
the opportunity to work with people
one-on-one you don't use the same
technique on everybody yeah you just
you're curious and you're great at that
you like you no I some people have to
follow a process they they're not good
in the gray areas and so they need a
script for telemarketing they need a
process and they will follow the process
and if you deviate they get flustered
and freak out that's not you like you
live in the crazy and the gray and the
where are we going next like you're you
excel in that so just bring that to the
conversations you're having I like that
before you ever get the coaching yeah
it's good stuff yeah to see me coaching
another entrepreneur one-on-one check
the video right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there we all have these
ideas I want to start a podcast I want
to be a speaker the successful people
they're not smarter than you often
they're probably stupider than you they
just start